le business des ehpad leur grille a le
vent en poupe
une maison de retraite est plus rentable
qu'un centre commercial
avez vous conscience d'être complice de
cette escroquerie épouvantable ses
actionnaires bien ils devraient tous les
matins l'argent on regarde et
l'argentine nationaux retentissent et la
sueur et la maltraitance les gens qu'on
appelle pour qui le gagne et ce qu'ils
font
[Musique]
notre gouvernement qui jusqu'à présent
n'a jamais rien fait pour soutenir nos
données dans une structure pour soutenir
tous les français qui sont dans
l'obligation de mettre leurs parents
dans une structure physique pour qui
l'heure de l'objectif et le rendement un
individu je veux bien mais quand vous
avez des millions de familles des
millions de résidents des millions de
soignants qui répète la même chose dans
toutes les ehpad privée en france à but
lucratif
c'est une polaire une réalité c'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui dans les ehpad
privé lucratif
[Musique]
je ferais preuve et avec de gilles
bourguignon nous y veillerons croyez moi
à la plus grande sévérité si le serait
ce qu'un pourcentage des faits qui sont
alléguées dans le livre devait s'avérer
vrai nous deviendrons tous les moyens
pour vérifier la réalité de ces faits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]